okay I don't I don't think I don't think
it's cheap I don't think it's cheated
are you are you are your business or
anything are you uh this is just like
how what percent of people have business
no I'm not I'm just trying to okay I'm
just trying to because yeah I know I
know there's exceptions but yeah we're
talking about the rule all right cool so
if we're dealing with that then then
public profile then it's a red flag it's
not cheating but it's a red flag because
that's the Prelude to cheating up being
married having a public profile yeah
public yeah yeah all right second one
for a girl same thing red flag
not really you know
open yeah like you're open to messages
like Drake can DM you oh cool man this
is something I believe right
okay what are you willing to do for your
for your husband that you have never
done for another man right and you're
not gonna come with virginity because
you're um I'm saying if you're not a
virgin then you're not coming with with
your youth like with your with your
Purity right a lot of women are coming
in
foreign a lot of bodies and and a lot of
experience here a lot of trauma right so
you come with all of these things right
so if a man sees you with all of these
things and he said you know what forget
the bodies forget everything that's gone
um forget the age I'm willing to come in
and wife you and put a ring on your
finger but the one thing that I just I
require for you is that once we get
married I would appreciate if you could
come off Instagram are we this is coming
off Instagram I'm going private or to
coming off Instagram I'd appreciate if
you come off Instagram
um because you know I don't really want
you same access to people that you know
that could have access to Prior and this
includes all the the the all your
orbiters all your ex guys Drake all
these people just in case you never know
no because Drake and Floyd Mayweather do
DM people average girls and then and
they destroy average guys life they've
been seen to do it you know what I'm
trying to say to you and this is the
thing they can at any moment so you know
and if your wife isn't willing to do
that then it says to me that she's
holding on so not everyone uses
so basically if you're married and then
you say oh yeah I'm gonna keep it open
I'm a modern that's how I make money oh
man that's how we're going to feed our
kids
you're going to feed the kids of modern
you're gonna feed your kids off the main
thing that your husband does
I will never ever ever depend on a man's
money it's not about the people it is
when you marry a ma when when you get
married the two income household okay
I'll I'll make my money my partner will
make it it's not your money
it's the family's money your money is
your own well not in my it wouldn't be
my household my money will be the Family
household money I'll pay the bills with
it he can pay such people who probably
pay the lights I probably paid the
mortgage it's a team here 50 50. I don't
mind if you want to do like a joint bank
account like I just feel like if you're
married you might as well I had a joint
bank account okay it doesn't bother me
you're the father of my child it does
not bother me
after we split up we okay so so all
right who thinks it's cheating having IG
no no no no anyone anyone think it is
for a girl no it's not cheating but it's
a huge red flag so I'll I'll put some
red if you're married yeah one red flag
no because the ward says the board says
having IG
TR has an IG yeah
anything on there
she is she said open public yeah that's
a red flag all right all right okay all
right all right having having Tinder
they just want to see who's out there
they're not using it
no no no okay okay
holiday pictures on Tinder
don't put me in there what's the Devil's
Advocate position with that it's like
it's like it's like a woman or a woman
goes outside we just get hit on we have
people move to us all the time right
where a man he doesn't necessarily get
that he has to do it so if he has a
Tinder profile like it's just basically
the attention we get on a daily basis
Devil's Advocate so the man wants to be
a woman now
so now next
no not over here
does anyone does anyone have anything
else they want to put on the board or as
a question for cheating or not cheating
having um okay oh I have a partner
friends I've been boyfriends yeah yeah I
haven't made attention that isn't your
man no I don't think it's Mr I don't
think it's true no I mean like opposite
obviously having a close friend that's a
male yes I live there next to you you
don't think that's true yeah it's it's
cheating yes for me you tell it what are
you telling this guy that you can't tell
your man
I have a really close phone I could see
that as a best friend and he's a male is
he gay is it gay do you guys sleep in
the same bed no you don't sleep in the
same place
in the same bed he's not gay I knew him
when he was single when he was a Playboy
like nothing happened I watched him grow
and get married he's married I watched
him grow and get married
so and I so so now when he's at home do
you call it no I don't I that's the
thing I respect his partner
and I understand he has a family so I
won't call him at a pacific time I won't
call him let's say let's say past seven
o'clock or something because he's got a
daughter now situations do change but
the love and the friendship that I have
with him
today today yeah so so panel panel in
this situation right here she gets she
gets married yeah is she cheating or not
cheating all right
hands we like hands here
I'm sorry
for the girls okay you'll see give me
something for your boyfriend can't
provide yeah what about him is he
cheating in this situation yeah they got
even more more than the female he works
both ways someone is always compensating
someone is always compensated with
someone is always
exactly
put the other person in the friend zone
this is how it works men and women can't
be friends in it yeah I'm only friends
with ghosts because I don't have an
attraction to them
exactly
he doesn't have an attraction to me I
don't have an attraction to him but if
if we had that we would have been no no
years ago from school no but I'm saying
it's never happened I want to ask guys
guys have you ever been friends with a
girl for years never hooked up with her
but you would 100 facts yeah yeah okay
that's like 90 of them
I really don't like that because we just
have friends no but I am your friend but
you're asking me something I'm a man all
right you just plot if you want to test
go you see you know what yeah your best
friend that you think is your male
friend here just message him and say oh
you know what I just broke up with my
man you know I'm just feeling really
good oh what do you call him right now
[Music]
that's the whole point like it's an
inappropriate call where's my phone I
don't even have my phone here
but you need to you need to tell him
what we're telling you to sell him no
but he might say something else
listen I'm feeling really lonely I'm
feeling really low like I know I've
spoke to you like this before but I just
really want you no he's married don't
create these no I wouldn't I wouldn't
there wouldn't be a problem if he's
loyal it doesn't matter see this is a
thing see you already know he's not your
friend because you don't even want to
create a scenario I don't want to put
someone into that City I can't be
friends no no I don't agree
to that situation where how can you put
him to something he's gonna say no he's
gonna say no calling him he's your
brother huh he's your brother what are
you doing
I've known him for very long time if
something could have happened it would
have happened years ago so he's not
attracted to me
does anyone else have a male friend they
want to test on stream anyone no I think
it's okay what about what about you the
bed sleeper I don't keep male friends
personally I don't I'm a big believer
that Mellows and females can't be
friends because she knows I know no I
know I know men personally I feel like
it's they can't come they can't do it
without intentions you know just for
that just for that that's what I'm not
trust me I've learned
my mistakes trust me
I'll give you one I'll get rid of one my
problem thank you thank you my partner
can have female friends I wouldn't care
I'm not a jealous person and vice versa
has nothing to do about it it's jealousy
if you loved your partner and you valid
him you would understand that and he's a
man of value these people are going to
see what I've got and they're gonna
throw it at my man you like you're
trusting these girls because you gotta
remember there's not enough of these men
around so if you really got yourself a
catch and they know he's got a catch
they're gonna take that catch from you
you're not married literally you're not
married so he's not yours I would never
ever have an issue with my partner
having female friends that's just me no
but I'm not saying that I'm saying he's
not having issue he's not married I
would never have it I would never have
it he's not married if I met you today
yeah see the way I look at it is if a
woman hasn't got a ring on her finger
she's fair game and the reason it is is
you've had previous previous
relationships before that he was like
I've got a man I've got a man you're not
with them anymore because you didn't
have a ring on it they just previous
relationship so unless A girl has got a
ring on her finger I know already I can
I can I can I can I can affect this you
know why because if your man really
wanted you he would have married you he
doesn't want you because he hasn't
married you and this is the truth for
the matter men know what we want and
when we see something that we want we
lock it down that's why when we're
outside and we see a good girl there's
not a lot of good girls there's a lot of
girls you can sleep with take out posts
on the ground look good you know what
I'm trying to say to you but there's not
many girls you can bring home when you
find one one two three four guys are all
competing for that one girl because
there's not that many but when it comes
to sleeping around we can get that from
anywhere that's all I'm trying to say so
when it comes down to men and me
personally I wouldn't keep a pretty
woman like you like as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible